et des français qui devrait faire face à
une hausse des prix qui s'accélère dans
le pays avec un pic de plus de 1 9% en
août du jamais vu en trois ans
l'inflation un phénomène général en
cette période de reprise posco vide
alors comment expliquer cette poussée
soudaine des prix cette flambée est elle
une menace pour le pouvoir d'achat quels
sont les risques de style l'inflation
c'est-à-dire l'inflation sans croissance
une fois l'euphorie de la reprise
passait on voit ça tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir c'est notre
rubrique l'édito échos
bonsoir jacques merci d'être avec nous
alors cette inflation dont on parle à
est ce que finalement c'est un phénomène
purement français où ça concerne
d'autres pays également alors oui vous
avez tout à fait raison de parler de
stagnation au départ non c'est un
phénomène général on le voit par exemple
au niveau des états unis qui sont
actuellement à 5,4 pour cent d'inflation
s'ils voulaient c'est énorme parce
qu'ils étaient pratiquement à zéro au
mois de janvier on le voit en europe
dans l'union européenne
ou on est pour les prix industriels
autour de 2,3 pour cent et on le voit
aussi en france avec un taux d'environ
1,9 pour cent alors un jacques pour la
france dont quelle est la situation
précisément alors pourront là pour la
france si vous voulez la situation c'est
la suivante on n'a eu pratiquement une
inflation qui a fortement baissé dans
l'année 2020 et qui a commencé à
redémarrer à partir de janvier février
de cette année alors ça peut se
comprendre on a eu les deux confinement
de 2020 ça évidemment casser
complètement l'activité ce qui est quand
même intéressant c'est de voir que quand
l'inflation repart le troisième
confinement ne l'affectait pas et
évidemment depuis la sortie du 3ème
confinement là l'inflation suivant les
chiffres de l'insee accélère et comme je
le disais elle atteint maintenant 1,9
pour cent alors quels sont les produits
qui ont le plus contribué à cette
inflation alors comme en europe qui est
évidemment une hausse assez sensible des
produits industriels mais ce qui est
intéressant dans le cas de la france
c'est de voir que
les produits agricoles des produits
alimentaires aussi on monte de manière
assez conséquente est là encore si on se
réfère à l'insee il y à une hausse
d'environ 10% mais je dirais à partir
d'un niveau qui était effectivement très
bas au départ d'environ 10% depuis sept
huit mois donc là aussi il y a un effet
d'inflation qui est très nette
évidemment la question qu'on pose
pourquoi de telles hausses oui
évidemment c'est une question qu'on peut
se poser alors d'abord il faut savoir il
y à des ruptures de production ou plus
précisément la demande est repartie
beaucoup plus vite koné repartir la
production sa cause des phénomènes de
pénurie et c'est pilgrim dame en font
monter les prix c'est le cas
particulièrement des semi conducteurs il
ya aujourd'hui plusieurs usines en
allemagne et en france qui sont au
chômage technique à cause de cette
question après il ya un problème global
de hausse des matières premières et sa
touche et ça c'est intéressant toutes
les matières premières qu'il s'agisse
des matières premières agricoles
problème en france mais qu'il s'agisse
aussi du pétrole qui est passé de
environ 40 dollars le baril au début de
cette année à 70 dollars actuellement et
les métaux enfin il ya un problème que
l'on a tendance à négliger mais qui est
très important c'est la désorganisation
des modes de transports la
désorganisation de la logistique il ya
des porcs qui ont été bloqués à cause de
la crise de l'aco vide en chine en
particulier et on voit que le prix du
transport est en train d'augmenter très
fortement alors c'est intéressant
effectivement mais vous ne parlez pas de
la politique des banques centrales est
ce qu'elle aurait quelque chose à voir
maintenant je vous vois venir alors
effectivement la politique des banques
centrales elle joue mais elle ne joue
pas sur cette inflation elle va jouer
beaucoup plus sur l'inflation de ce
qu'on appelle les actifs patrimoniaux
alors lancé des actifs patrimoniaux ya
évidemment les actions les obligations
et on voit bien aujourd'hui le marché de
paris comme l'ensemble des marchés
financiers est un des plus hauts
historiques
mais ça touche aussi par exemple le prix
des logements et là un phénomène qui est
assez intéressant on voit que bon double
que ce soit les
les appartements ou les maisons tout
cela ça monte depuis sept huit mois
aujourd'hui les appartements stagne
voire reubess un petit peu pourquoi
parce que les gens à cause des
confinement se dit on n'a pas envie
d'être confiné dans un appartement on
veut pouvoir acheter une maison si
possible avec un petit terrain pour que
les gosses puissent jouer etc et là on
voit que le prix des maisons augmentent
de manière très sensible alors on en
parlait tout à l'heure à ce fait un
risque de stagflation
clairement aujourd'hui comme certains le
redoutent et on en parlait oui alors
effectivement faut d'abord rappeler que
la stagflation c'est une situation où on
a de manière combinée une inflation
forte et une croissance nulle ou
extrêmement faible alors aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le risque le plus évident pour
deux raisons la première raison c'est
que évidemment on voit bien qu'il ya des
causes techniques à cette inflation et
puis la deuxième raison c'est que il ya
toujours un un chômage qui est assez
important en particulier en france mais
c'est quand même aussi vrai largement en
europe et tant qu'il y aura ce chômage
on peut penser qu'il n'y aura pas de
cesse d'en voler des salaires et des
coûts salariaux maintenant l'autre
problème c'est que cette inflation est
elle détériore le pouvoir d'achat et en
particulier le pouvoir d'achat des
salariés les plus faibles parce qu'il
faut bien voir que dans la hausse
moyenne des salaires que l'on a connu
malgré tout malgré l'épidémie eh bien
elle est tirée par les salaires les plus
élevés et les salaires du médian
inférieur autrement dit elle ils ont
inférieurs à la moitié et bien soit y
sont restés stables soit ilombe était
donc qu'est ce que ça veut dire bien ça
veut dire que le gouvernement va être
sous une pression très forte d'une part
pour augmenter de manière substantielle
le smic et puis d'autre part et ça c'est
aussi un problème qu'il faut relier je
dirais aux pénuries de main-d'oeuvre
qu'on a sectoriellement à si vous voulez
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'entreprise qui
soit aujourd'hui en france
ok par manque de main d'oeuvre mais on a
des pénuries qui sont qui peuvent
apparaître de manière relative
sectoriellement est dit il va y avoir
nécessairement une hausse des salaires
dans les mois qui viennent l'inflation
donc à surveiller comme le lait sur le
feu je suis avec vous jacques sapir
merci à vous et à très bientôt